son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
ante la otan el presidente de Ucrania
pidió apoyo a los países europeos para
ingresar a esa Alianza transatlántica y
a la Unión Europea esto al tiempo que
expertos del organismo internacional de
energía atómica explicaron que pese a
los bombardeos del fin de semana contra
la planta nuclear de saporiya el equipo
clave permaneció intacto en la
instalación
así 162 aumentó el número de víctimas
tras el terremoto de magnitud a 5,6 que
sacudió este lunes a Indonesia más de
700 personas resultaron heridas y
alrededor de 13.000 se vieron forzadas a
desplazarse la búsqueda de
sobrevivientes continúa
Disney recuperó a Robert dentro de su
planilla Quien fuera presidente
ejecutivo durante 15 años ahora fue
nombrado consejero delegado con efecto
inmediato al cierre del viernes las
acciones de la compañía habían caído
alrededor de un 40% en lo que va del año
solo el lunes en las operaciones previas
a la apertura del mercado habían subido
casi un 10%.
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos inicio en Ucrania porque el
presidente voló dimirselensky participó
de manera virtual en la asamblea
parlamentaria de la otan donde pidió
Europa que brinde apoyo a su país para
ingresar a la alianza transatlántica y a
la Unión Europea al tiempo el mandatario
reiteró que los soldados rusos que
controlan la planta nuclear de esa
polilla deben abandonar el lugar esto
luego de que el fin de semana se
reportaran bombardeos por los que mos se
acusan mutuamente
los ucranianos no solo
creense
ucranianos están seguros de que podemos
defendernos nosotros mismos en esta
guerra y devolver las fronteras de una
Europa unida a todo lo largo de nuestras
fronteras orientales y meridionales
después de una semana de haber liberado
gerson del control ruso algunos espacios
de la ciudad intentan volver a la
normalidad los ucranianos han celebrado
la recuperación de la estrategica ciudad
en catedrales supermercados teatros y
otros espacios comunes veamos más en el
informe de Juan Pablo
Este es el primer supermercado ucraniano
que abre sus puertas en la recién
recuperada gerson ha pasado una semana
desde que las tropas ucranianas
volvieron a tener el control de la
estratégica ciudad el rublo y los
productos traídos por Rusia empiezan a
desaparecer yo no tenía rublos y nunca
compré productos rusos Hoy es el primer
día del lanzamiento de nuestro
supermercado favorito con productos
ucranianos por eso estoy aquí Quiero
comprar algo rico ni siquiera estamos
seguros de que comprar porque en
realidad necesitaríamos todos los
productos los precios Son muy buenos
pero no caben todos en nuestro carrito y
la cola es tan larga que llevamos dos
horas esperando aquí
pero no en todos los espacios será fácil
regresar a la normalidad Ucrania acusa a
Rusia de haber saqueado casi 15.000
artefactos del Museo de Arte de gerson
el Ministerio de cultura del país
contabiliza por lo menos un 80% de la
colección perdida pero esperan
recuperarlo todo cuanto antes bajo la
idea de que el arte es necesario para
sus ciudadanos en estos tiempos de
guerra
hemos liberado el teatro es gratis ahora
y comenzará a funcionar Tan pronto como
podamos Tan pronto como haya
electricidad realizaremos las primeras
actuaciones traeremos el elenco de kiev
el primer tren desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa también empezó a funcionar
este fin de semana una catedral ortodoxa
y otras zonas de área común fueron otros
de los espacios en donde los ucranianos
celebraron la liberación de la ciudad
por otro lado sin dar muchas
explicaciones el presidente ucraniano
aseguró haber encontrado sitios de
tortura en otra acusación para las
tropas rusas y su huella en la ciudad
cambiamos de tema Durante los últimos 20
años la edad de jubilación en Dinamarca
se ha [__] constantemente para
garantizar las pensiones el gobierno ha
vinculado a la edad de retiro a la
esperanza de vida entonces un danés
nacido en 1979 se jubilará a los 72 años
pero también se alienta a los daneses a
trabajar el mayor tiempo posible incluso
Más allá de la edad legal de jubilación
porque el país sufre escasez de mano de
obra veamos
ha sido médico investigador y director
de hospital pero a los 78 años se
encuentra su nueva carrera en un
supermercado de igual de satisfactoria
fleming roose simplemente no está listo
para renunciar al trabajo
conozco a cada uno de mis clientes
muchos por su nombre conozco a sus hijos
los he visto crecer y todos los días que
voy a trabajar Estoy feliz de quién
viene hoy
en este país que envejece donde el
número de trabajadores activos cae cada
año más y más personas mayores como
fleming Bruce leaf seguirán trabajando
porque en Dinamarca la edad de
jubilación está indexada en función de
la esperanza de vida ahora son 68 pero
para obtener una pensión pronto tendrás
que tener 72 o 74 para los daneses
nacidos después del año 2000 así en
copenhague como en una veintena de
municipios más las agencias de empleo
especializadas acompañan a las personas
mayores en su búsqueda de trabajo
la mayoría de las personas en nuestra
sociedad en Dinamarca son las personas
que son debido a sus trabajos eso es muy
importante a qué te dedicas Esa es la
primera pregunta que te hacen en
Dinamarca para ayudar a mantener
empleados a los adultos mayores es
ilegal que las empresas pregunten a los
solicitantes de empleo su edad y a
partir del próximo año el gobierno no
grabará los salarios de los jubilados
solo queremos incentivar incluso 5 horas
de trabajo 10 horas de trabajo 15 horas
de trabajo y también creemos que si
tiene la salud y la fuerza para hacerlo
también aumentará el valor ordinario de
la vida de las personas mayores así como
la producción en la sociedad
Así que es una vida hecha de más y más
trabajo en Dinamarca la tasa de empleo
de más de 55 años es mayor al 70%. en
Francia es del 56%. en Europa las luces
navideñas comienzan a encenderse a pesar
de las restricciones energéticas que
atraviesa el continente debido al
recorte suministro de gas Ruso y a la
guerra en Ucrania París y Buscar esta se
preparan para iniciar las festividades
aunque con una reducción del gasto
energético según las autoridades
a pesar de la crisis energética que
azota a Europa el espíritu navideño
llega a las calles en la famosa Avenida
de los campos elíseos prendieron
millones de luces algunos turistas
justifican el gasto
hay que tener algo de Alegría en la vida
y quiero decir mira cuánta gente hay
aquí nos ha unido a todos
Definitivamente creo que vale la pena
según la administración cambiaron los
horarios para ayudar a la política de
ahorro del gobierno y las luces son de
bajo consumo estos nuevos horarios son
una forma de mostrarnos solidarios de
ser ahorradores de ser sostenibles y
razonables y de respetar el medio
ambiente en bucarest inauguraron la
feria navideña en alcalde de la capital
rumana dice que a pesar de los malos
tiempos que atraviesa Europa la Navidad
es importante
no son los mejores tiempos que estamos
atravesando Y al menos para las
vacaciones de invierno debemos estar
contentos las denominadas medidas de
sobriedad en Europa están activas en un
momento en que el comercio trata de
atraer a los compradores convertir unas
luminosas con la guerra en Ucrania
activa las sanciones a Rusia y los
problemas latentes con el suministro de
Vegas ruso por el norte Extreme 1 se
espera una fría de Navidad donde los
hogares pagarán un alto precio por la
energía en el invierno
La Isla dejaba en Indonesia se recupera
después del Fuerte sismo que provocó
hasta el momento la muerte de una 162
personas y más de 700 heridos las
autoridades Siguen trabajando en la
evaluación de daños y generar atención
algunas zonas Rurales mientras La
amenaza de réplicas fuertes Sigue
estando latente
un temblor de magnitud 5,6 sobre la
escala de richter hasta los rascacielos
de yakarta la capital de Indonesia se
vieron sacudidos por el sismo este lunes
cuyo epicentro se situó a 10 kilómetros
de profundidad en sianjur una urbe de la
isla de Java occidental la región más
poblada del país por el momento las
autoridades reportaron más de un
centenar de víctimas mortales y más de
700 heridos
muchas casas han sido destruidas en los
pueblos y necesitamos equipos pesados
para ello y muchas carreteras han sido
cortadas todavía estamos recopilando
datos al respecto
3000 personas tuvieron que ser evacuadas
y un millar de casa resultaron dañadas
los trabajadores de emergencia tuvieron
que atender a los heridos en camillas
fuera de los principales hospitales en
Terrazas y parqueaderos
todo nuestro personal médico incluidos
los que están en días libres y fuera de
turno ha entrado en servicio para la
medicina tenemos suficiente porque
recibimos el apoyo de la agencia de
salud local solo Esperamos que no haya
más réplicas
según la agencia meteorológica y
geofísica en las dos horas posteriores
al terremoto se registraron 25
réplicas mientras las autoridades
trabajan para determinar la magnitud de
los daños causados hay preocupación por
posibles deslizamientos de tierra en
caso de lluvias torrenciales
Disney anunció el regreso de Bob I girl
al frente de la compañía una llamada de
la experiencia para hacer frente a los
malos resultados económicos de la
empresa fue director ejecutivo de Disney
durante 15 años y se retiró a finales de
2021 tras el anuncio de su regreso las
acciones de la compañía subieron un 9,2%
este lunes alcanzando su mejor valor en
dos años
el anuncio llegó por sorpresa a la sede
de California Bob iger regresa a Walt
Disney Company como director ejecutivo
menos de un año después de haberse
retirado quien fue responsable de las
adquisiciones de Pixar Marvel o Twenty
First Century Fox vuelve a petición de
los dirigentes del grupo que confían en
él para revertir la mala tendencia
económica de la compañía
la junta concluyó que dado que Disney
entra en un período cada vez más
complejo de transformación de la
industria Bob aiger cuenta con una
situación única para dirigir la compañía
en este periodo crucial de este modo Bob
Iker pone fin a su breve jubilación tras
15 años al frente de Disney en 2020 dejó
el cargo pero permaneció en la empresa
hasta finales de 2021 para facilitar la
transición a su sucesor bobchapeck que
ya renunció durante su corta dirección
chapex se enfrentó al cierre de los
parques debido a la pandemia a las
críticas por tardar en defender los
derechos lgbt y q más en Florida sobre
todo a los malos resultados económicos
Bob iger rehereda ahora una situación
difícil las acciones de Disney cayeron
un 40% en lo que va de 2022 en parte por
los malos resultados del servicio de
streaming Disney Plus que ya ha generado
pérdidas de 1.500 millones de dólares en
el último trimestre a los 71 años de
edad hay que regresa por un periodo de
24 meses tras el cual elegirá a su
próximo sucesor y el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden protagonizó la
tradicional ceremonia del indulto del
pavo de Acción de Gracias en la casa
blanca distintas Fuentes citan el origen
de esta tradición en la presidencia de
Abraham Lincoln al que su hijo le habría
pedido que perdonara al animal para que
no fuera sacrificado en la comida
familiar este año se conmemora
oficialmente la edición número 75 de la
ceremonia y vaiden indultó a los pavos
chocolate y chip
Argentina juega su primer partido en el
mundial de Qatar Este martes frente
Arabia Saudita con todos los ojos
puestos sobre el Astro del fútbol Lionel
Messi quien nunca ha ganado mundial en
Rosario su ciudad natal cada vez son más
las personas que hacen fuerza para que
la estrella de la albiceleste logre
conquistar este galardón
en la ciudad de Rosario Argentina
imposible no admirar al hijo pródigo del
país es aquí a 3000 kilómetros de Buenos
Aires la capital que nació la estrella
del fútbol Lionel Messi fue el primero
primero de los murales que se pintaron
por fuera de esta movida de desde hace
cuatro años Victoria López organiza
visitas guiadas por el barrio de
infancia del delantero argentino
Messi despierta simpatías en todo el
mundo y especialmente acá donde los
propios vecinos se sienten más
orgullosos de haber palpado algo y haber
sido parte de alguna manera de la
construcción de este mito y este Dios
que que es mes en la calle donde creció
los vecinos organizan los preparativos
de cara al mundial están haciendo en un
retrato de Leo el mejor de todo el mundo
de acá de Argentina que hace alguna
locura armamos colgamos banderines
pintamos todo de Celeste y blanco y le
estamos dando toda el aliento a la
Argentina para que este año y esta copa
sea nuestra que tenemos que traer Messi
ya ha ganado siete balones de oro y el
año pasado con su selección argentina
consiguió la Copa América sin embargo el
título de campeón del mundo todavía se
le escapa a pesar de haber participado
cuatro veces en el mundial que estamos
esperando que Messi haga el mejor gol de
la historia yo creo que esta vez se nos
va a dar en Buenos Aires todo el mundo
quiere creer en la victoria en la tienda
de souvenirs El capitán de la selección
argentina va de la mano con Diego
Maradona que ganó el mundial en 1986
México se gana al mundial Messi ya queda
el legado de Messi para siempre para
toda la vida Argentina juega su primer
partido este martes a las 7 de la mañana
hora de Buenos Aires este bar abrirá
para la ocasión
Ellos están todas reservadas eso tiene
mucho que ver ese es el último mundial
de Messi a los 35 años con todo un país
Detrás de él Lionel Messi iba a intentar
conseguir el último título que le falta
en su palmarés así llegamos al final de
esta emisión de directo América a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ella llega a malbett con toda la
información del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]